let's get to this point where you're in
the church you were raised in the church
from a very early age your whole
family's in the church
and then there was an incident that
bothered you that started
i think you had questions before but in
2006
you go to a big wedding big celebrity uh
wedding
of uh tom cruise to katie holmes the
wedding and
you were friends with uh the wife
of kind of what is he called this the
chairman of the board of scientology
david uh is it miscavige
is the big cheese of scientology and
you're friends with his wife and you see
that his wife isn't there
right and you asked her name is shelley
where's shelley
there's this big wedding where's shelley
and what happened
well i asked innocently um you know
where's shelley because i thought it was
odd it was
being uh they were calling it the
wedding of the century the church
and i said well where's shelley
miscavige and with that was a reaction
of
you know people just scattering they
didn't want to have any part of this
um so people around you like got out of
there literally just
like scattered and i was like okay um
and and i
had gone to the to the church and i i
asked the the spokesperson at the time
tom davis
uh where is shelley i think it's weird
that she's not here
and he said you don't have the effing
rank
to be asking about the leader's wife and
i felt that i did have the f in rank to
ask where a human being was
right and she's your friend you're just
saying well i i you know you were saying
friends and and the church is saying you
know that we weren't friends
it was it is not usual for a parishioner
like me even though i was considered a
celebrity in my church
to be kind of mingling with the upper
echelon
of ex senior executives of the church
but we were friendly
um for for many years we exchanged cards
we exchanged gifts on the holidays she
always wrote a thank you note
so it was suspicious that all of a
sudden
it was just radio silence and so i felt
i did have the right to ask where a
human being was
um but there's ranks in in in the
organization and since then
uh do you know where where shelly
miscavige is now
i do not uh i filed a police report um
i i did not receive an actual
uh uh that the person who was in charge
of the case said that it was
um classified which is not usual
um that they couldn't give me any
information other than
she was fine i i needed proof i wanted
to know who
who uh spoke to her was she alone was
she okay
was are you sure i was she were you
talking to a representative of her
so i didn't get those specifics and of
course um
the the church is claiming that i that i
um
filed a an unfounded report which is a
classification that the lapd gives
um for for uh certain anyway they have
a certain nomenclature they use for
reports but they of course use that
to imply that i did it purposely and
that i knew where she was
i think one of the things when i was
just watching the show it's one of the
uh allegations in the show
that you that that and it's again this
is not just you you're talking to a lot
of people who
used to be in the church are not in the
church anymore and they're talking to
you and everyone's sharing their
experiences and i think that's what what
gives the series a lot of power is it's
people talking
and a lot of them talk about being
physically assaulted they'll disagree
with someone in the church who outranks
them and that person will just start
hitting them
correct and they say no one in the room
will do anything and the person who's
being assaulted actually says
i didn't do anything i just stood there
and let them hit me right and
i watch that as an adult and i don't
understand
how that's possible it's it's possible
because if you believe
that you have barred freeing
mankind that that that you're
transgression of not putting a cup where
it should be
or um somehow impeded the progress of
the church
correct correct and so they start to
believe that they deserve to be they
deserve this punishment correct
and that's how it it has
has continued
you